vsauce kevin here with 100
youtubers some are friends some are
colleagues
all are about to be demonetized forever
unless each one chooses their own
channel out of these
100 eggs i'll put one youtuber in each
egg and every player gets
only 50 guesses if just one of the 100
youtubers fails to find their channel
in the egg everyone loses here's the
setup
all 100 youtubers are in the same
waiting room
they're each assigned a number and then
one at a time
brought into the egg room to play the
game alone
once a youtuber completes their round
they're immediately
escorted out the back door so they can't
go back into the waiting room and say
like hey rhett and link you're hidden in
egg number 93 or whatever
no no that's cheating
this game is 50 blind guesses for each
youtuber
and they all have to find their egg or
everyone
is demonetized after each round the eggs
are all reset
and resealed so that the next youtuber
can't see
which has been chosen every player has
to start
fresh so how do you win when you can't
see what's in the eggs and you can't
communicate with
any other players the most obvious
option is for everyone to just
choose randomly and hope for the best i
mean you have
50 tries that's a lot right 50 out of
100 eggs gives you 50
50 odds of finding your egg not bad
but the odds of all 100 youtubers
pulling this off successfully
are virtually impossible let's crunch
the numbers
it's pretty simple with 100 eggs and 50
guesses
the odds of selecting the right egg
randomly are 50
or 0.5 100 successful attempts at
odds of 0.5 comes out to
[Music]
zero zero 0.000000 zero zero zero zero
zero zero
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero
zero zero zero eight
to get the percentage odds we just shift
the decimal over
two places and uh yeah there are still
28 zeros the odds of me getting drafted
in the nba
or winning the lottery are unfathomably
higher
than this demonetization egg game
working out
for these youtubers these odds are
literally the same as correctly
predicting
100 coin flips in a row
try it try to successively predict coin
flips
you may get five or six in a row right
maybe 10 but you almost certainly won't
get
50 let alone the 100 we need
to save our youtubers so sorry
three blue one brown and sorry epic rap
battles there's
just no hope of winning this game
your channels like everyone else is here
are cancelled unless
what if there was a mathematical
strategy that our 100 youtubers could
employ
to give their channels a realistic
chance
of survival let's actually play this
game and
try to figure it out i've given each of
these youtubers a number between 1 and
100 and each one will randomly go
in a numbered egg
now we've got 100 youtubers hidden in
100
eggs and the secret solution to saving
their channels goes
like this when it's their turn to play
each youtuber just
needs to start by choosing the numbered
egg
that matches their personally assigned
number
if they aren't in that egg rather than
choosing another egg
randomly the next egg to be opened
is the number of the youtuber inside the
one that they just opened each player
will repeat
this strategy until they find their egg
or
until they've opened 50 eggs
unsuccessfully
in which case everyone loses
max mofo is player number one so i will
play
as max mofo
here we go okay egg number one
is dust johnson who is number
62 all right so we'll just open up egg
number 62
and physics girl and she
is number 12. so now we just open up egg
number 12.
nerd city number 77 so let's open up
egg 77
number file number 35 okay
let's check out egg 35.
and here we have carson number
69. this is very very important whatever
you do
do not forget 69. we'll talk about that
later but for now let's open up egg 69
aspect science number seven um
you know what this actually might take a
little while so while i find the max
mofo channel
let's montage
20 20 is max
is me max mofo we did it we found
me well we found max and it only took
31 guesses way below our 50 guest
threshold
now we need to reset our eggs
okay we're all set for youtuber number
two red
letter media let's do this
[Music]
red letter media i found it already that
didn't take long at all okay
now let's reset and go with youtuber
number three
okay now it is time for danny gonzalez
here we go
danny gonzales number three did it again
another winner that is awesome okay
i am going to reset this and then
let's talk about what just happened
[Music]
okay our strategy is working three
youtubers have found their eggs
the odds of the first three youtubers
successfully choosing with
random guessing would have been point
five times point five
times point five which equals twelve and
a half percent
four in a row drops down to six point
two
five percent five in a row you're
looking at three point one
two five percent and by seven in a row
you're below
one percent so how much better is our
system
well remember that random guessing has
the odds of
all 100 youtubers winning at 0.000
28 zeros and then an 8
to put it in perspective our system
increases the odds more powerfully
than turning a penny into all the money
in the world
we can increase the odds of saving all
100 youtubers
from effectively zero percent to
31 percent and i'll explain how it works
but
here's a question did i just make this
whole thing
up no usually i like to examine old
long-standing problems in math and
science but
this one is actually pretty new in 2003
computer scientist peter bro milterson
and anagal in a paper titled the cell
probe complexity of succinct data
structures
created a version of this game in which
red or blue slips
were dropped in 100 little drawers
to win every single one of the 100
players had to correctly guess
whether their drawer contained a red or
a blue
slip the game is a little different but
the odds of
guessing red or blue versus choosing 50
eggs out of 100 are
exactly the same milterson's initial
thought was that as the number of
players
increases the probability of winning the
game would trend
to zero but by starting with the egg
matching their
own number each player is guaranteed
that they're on a path to an egg that
contains
them and it's just a question of whether
their egg is within
a cycle of 50 attempts
okay why because
each egg contains one unique number that
points to another unique number
and that creates as nick perry of data
genetics described
a circular chain one number points into
the chain and one number
points out so if the youtuber uses
their own number to point into the chain
they will eventually find
their own number rather than blindly
guessing
our system is a way of tapping in to
that
circular chain to get
mathy about it by giving each youtuber a
number we've created a permutation of
the set that's a one-to-one mapping
of all 100 numbers to itself
our strategy makes a cycle so each
number returns
to itself and it's successful when all
100 youtubers
find a cycle length of 50 or less
with 100 eggs there can only
mathematically be one cycle longer
than 50 but that's all it takes for us
to lose the game
anyway so what are the chances of a
permutation in which there's one cycle
longer than 50
let's find out the solution to our
chance of success equals 1
minus the probability of getting a cycle
longer than
50. let's call the cycle length l
that gives us 100 choose l possible
sets times l factorial over l
permutations of the cycle within the set
times 100 minus l factorial permutations
of the
remaining youtubers and that comes out
to
100 factorial over l which is
really really easy to work with we know
that there are 100 factorial ways to
arrange the tickets so
the probability of chain length l is
just
one over l our chance of success is
one minus all those long chain failures
combined
since we also know that only one cycle
of 51
or longer is possible in each set we can
calculate the probability of losing by
1 minus 1 over 51
plus 1 over 52 plus 1 over 53
etc 1 over 98 plus 1 over 99
plus 1 over 100 which comes out to about
0.69 i told you to remember
69 there's a 69
chance that we encounter a cycle longer
than 50.
so the probability of all 100 youtubers
having a cycle
of 50 or under which means they'd win
the demonetization game using this
strategy
is the remaining 0.31 or 31
31 isn't amazing but just like the game
of google
around 30 is way better than
basically zero the weird thing is that
even with
our solution each individual youtubers
chance of success
is still 50 just like if they
guessed randomly the strategy changes
the group's chance
of success so that's that problem
solved until you tweak the problem
milterson's game continues to evolve
like
what happens if we have more than 100
eggs but
some of them are empty reaching an
empty egg would stop the cycle and
completely ruin
our system but even this seemingly
impossible version of the game
has inspired computer scientists to
develop a strategy
that defies our expectations of failure
which is what we do whether we're
pretending the floor
is lava whether we're watching
superheroes defeat
galaxy destroying villains or we're
trying to cure diseases that seem
impossible
to overcome we test
push and expand our limits because
challenges
are only impossible until
they aren't and as always
thanks for watching
[Music]
you